first Minister can you confirm that the
transgender person who appeared in court
this morning Andrew Miller Amy George
will not be sent to a women's prison oh
first of all can I say that this is a
gut wrenching case heartbreaking I
cannot think of the trauma the victim
and the the family of the victim in fact
the community
are going through I can confirm of
course that Andrew Miller is being held
in a male prison but I can't see which
one and I can't go into the details and
will he continue to stay in a male
prison well again look this is a live
case the sentencing is still to happen
so I can't comment any further but of
course he is being held in the middle
estate but can you rule out that he will
not be moved to a women's prison I
cannot come in a life case and you
should know that